bientôt vous excuser aujourd'hui est un
grand jour parce qu'on va jouer un jeu
d'horreur et parce qu'on a plus de bars
appartement 666 c'est aussi le jeu qui a
le pire menu du monde mais il erre bien
là c'est un parcours serait dans un
appartement ouvre la porte derrière se
trouvent les vrais mensonges d'horreur
traduction approximative pour l'histoire
on se réveille chez nous comme ça notre
appartement et on n'arrive pas à s'en
échapper on va mettre le son bien faut
regarder regard des preuves
preuve que j'aime ils sont extrêmement
forts voilà le courage
alors on y va non cash sur la personne
c'est un mensonge ou autant de temps et
c'est berruyer d'accord déjà je passe
assez la crise cardiaque a pas se mentir
dans la vraie vie aisée et bagdad et
tout ça de mon côté tout seul ça tout
seul non il ya un petit esprit que votre
coupé la gorge
maman papa boîte on va tout casser ça
c'est de temps leur chambre et voilà le
fail et je me réveille même c'est génial
c'est comme pythie en fait courant pas
ce qui se passe en fait c'était en
nocturne et or ne purge pas s'il a déjà
fait j'espère pas en gros tu fais un
cauchemar
et quand tu te réveilles ça recommence
en fait c'est jamais réveillé mais tu
crois que tu te réveiller donc tu es
encore plus peur pop ça sauve pas des
mecs mais fuit et c'est quoi ce bruit de
couinements y ait un effort physique
fait la balançoire pas loin effrayant à
ya une note b non non abuser c'est abusé
mexes sound effect je suis sûr car dans
la vidéo ce sera le truc le plus vendu
le à la fois d'histoire et appris que sa
soeur se soit fait assassiner sur des
bonnes nouvelles dans les journaux ces
jeux sont personnelles sur les suspects
principaux
ok mais attention ici un vrai screamer
et que c'est aussi fort du jeu wii de
papier vous payer la location du
défibrillateur pour brady mère allait
way qui est la c3 qui se passe et ils
parlaient plus yamaha enfin il ferme ses
fesses il a compris et l'a compris qui
rate
mais en fait c'est de la flûte qui joue
de la flûte comme une merde qui se prend
pour carlos dont bob l'eponge c'est quoi
ce bruit montre-toi was as much better
c'est quoi ce bruit de mort c'est plus
bas dans que tout ce que tu peux trouver
dans cette maison le elle lui dit ah
c'est beaucoup mieux que je me casse ça
on se tire bas mot papa aulas était au
calme à la commission c'est ça y a pas
de toilettes
pourquoi cette baignoire fait des bruits
toilettes roubia cherche de baignoires
fait un truc c'est pas bon je prends pas
en baladant à il y avait un truc
intéressant
voilà du coup maintenant on peut se
marrer maintenant qu'on a lu le journal
pour la deuxième fois voilà et il se
réveille c'est qu'il ya des terreurs
nocturnes j'en parlais tout à l'heure
qui peuvent durer comme ça mais pendant
je suis battu j'ai travaillé genre six
fois et 6 fois tu crois que tu t'es
vraiment réveillé et cette faute est
encore dans tout ce qui s'est passé là
nos forgive nasa excuses refusé ok il a
vraiment l'air paniqué le garçon - au
derrière et on pas qu'il est en train de
lire un script s'ouvre enfin effet un
jeu d'horreur s'il ya des tableaux et du
sort et des tableaux bonbons ce caza
tranche ce jeu on se réveille [ __ ] qui
s'y attendait a la chance d'avoir un mec
là on nous la part de quelqu'un et bien
non tout est de retour à la normale ce
qui est encore plus fort mais avoir un
mec je suis sûr qu'un mec
oui on va y aller tout doux je suis sûr
qu'ils aient un mec ah [ __ ]
à l'époque c'est vraiment la personne du
monde quoi à l'eau aux arts et aux
boîtes
c'est ça qui s'est ouvert mais elle n'a
jamais été ouverte avant bonne question
garçons et on m'enferme même parfait hu
qui tape alors on lit le journal
je l'entendis simon biatoss pas le même
journal cette fois une merdique sont
enfin les pouvoirs
elle a dit qu'il devrait parler à des
créatures watts 14 morts dont la soeur
de l'enfant kidnappé dans le massacre au
parc ok c'est le seul euro avec la sas
et commence à faire beaucoup la lrm
l'apport qu'est-ce qu'il ya barrière
mais qu'est-ce qui va sonner cette fois
c'est vrai qu'au reste en forme avant ça
fait dix-huit fois qu'ils se réveillent
qui vit la même chose et plus bastia aux
mots que en courant s'est en plus vite
trop haut
c'est plus la salle de bain non ici
c'est une chambre
la baisse les effets de son dans ton jeu
bordel est en train de mourir
on a quoi en est une lampe on n'avait
qu'un journal du lean avait une soeur et
un plus petit frère et ils ont tous les
deux été tuées dans la tuerie du parc du
coup est-ce que je suis le gars on
m'envoie ou pas
nani qui pleure cette larve ça venait de
la mec tu vous jure je me croyais pas ok
vous qui croit que je deviens fou je
voulais que ça venait de cette lan
n'allons pas pleurer mais c'est tout
alors on ressort on se calme oh on a une
entorse mais qu est-ce que c'est bon
signe pas du tout arrêter ex la loge
arrive malheur jari matti
allez on va chez toi pour ça va aller ça
va aller mais déjà je propose à cette
langue de l'aider elle me répond en
explosant et ensuite j'ai fait le malin
au début de la vidéo comme on peut le
voir on va mettre le son bien faut
regarder real et preuve
preuve que j'aime ils sont extrêmement
fortes et je regrette parce que le son
du jeu est mal équilibré allons diva
ouais quelle est cette pièce la pièce à
chaise mettez une chaise contre un mur
dans une petite pièce aux murs est la
pièce la plus mal lotie arrête
j'en ai marre de cette loi bon ben on va
la chambre des parents on va se
réveiller c'est ça [ __ ] c'est dommage
et des bus était cool mais là il nous
fait faire trop de tours alors qu'il se
passe rien du coup on avait dû à pokémon
go basse quoi faire c'est simple c'est
que je fais me met à courir
allô maman y'a un fantôme juste derrière
moi l'eau maman voilà c'était sr ch et
donc
oh ben ça part en couille ça j'adore ça
la porte de gauche maintenant c'est le
même couloir même le chapeau il a kiffé
ils partent
boisvenu
ça va faire mal la tortue c'est vrai
remake c'est la panique
on se casse la gueule à et magané avec
sa chanson péter là n'ont pu faire un
feat avec annie au moins aller papa
maman prenez votre bol de corn flakes
ethnique et vous voilà ils sont pourquoi
là
c'est un enfant c'est une araignée nan
et ses narines et qui a mangé un enfant
allait à a+ la réunion fort et c'est
reparti mais c'est allé le journal je
suis fier de toi julian ce que tu as
fait au parc aulas tu es frère du
meurtrier qui nous a tous égaux mais
c'est sa maman qui s'adresse à moi et
que moi j'ai sauvé des gens je sais rien
aaaaaah connard tu peux pas bien joué
connais tu connais la pression dit d'y
être non de booba de mayol de booba nagl
nice ou maillol donc l'avancé ça c'est
juste un mec qui en asile psychiatrique
et qui en plus fait rire le moins
naturelles du monde pour exprimer sa
folie utah alors là savent pas qu'ils
ont des pages du magasin tout tuer la
gnagna plutôt positif trois évaluations
alors là oh my god i and was insein like
inception j'aimais marché dans les
couloirs encore et encore
m'embrouiller avec une ampoule voir une
baignoire faire le bruit de chiottes
mais j'ai surtout aimé la chaise seul
dans 1 2 mètre carré [ __ ] à la douille
vengeance la vingtaine ont sur
appartements sont sentis tester pas
aller mais ça vous a plu mine de rien
c'est quand même un mec seul qui a fait
ce jeu avec de 17 ans dont c'est quand
même très fort reçoit pas le faire
galoper les mécaniques de pythie à
l'époque qui sont refaire le même truc
en boucle à aider des éléments qui
change qui te stresse énormément sur
calais y en a un peu trop fait
il s'est dit vraiment on va refaire le
même couloir 600 fois jusqu'à ce que le
bec soient dégoûtés et matin pottow
pouces rouge que quand il ouvre un
journal le bruit du papier lui explose
la gueule par eux c'est moi je me suis
enflammé
c'était à lutter un char et